let's go for it then come on tom
you know live chat thank you anyway good
morning everybody
uh i'm supposed to speak into this my
microphone i think
uh welcome to this meeting um
i'm hoping that everything goes all
right for us and nobody
catches anything so let's just
take it as it comes okay um
we'll go on to
[Music]
the agenda apologist for absence then
kirsten apologies from councillor cottle
hunting and
councillor ninten will be late okay
public contributions have we got anybody
no
minutes to the last meeting everybody
i've after
everybody's read the last two minutes of
the last meeting
um i'll just go through facebook page
phase three
third paragraph i don't want page third
paragraph but you want to
stage five page five okay
third paragraph yeah
i haven't received anything where
anybody else received anything have they
this way
that's all right thank you yeah no we'll
we'll chase out thank you
okay six
seven
[Music]
oh
uh
okay
okay
um
i item for action list page nine and ten
uh i'll just say that like on my ipad i
went through the agenda of minutes and
documents and put the notes on it
and now i can't access it because it
needs to be updated
and it's really frustrating so
you know i don't know what points i was
going to erase
your ipads got updated last night or
well-minded but i forgot mine
but um so
i i i haven't got a clue what you can do
the service provider never gave us
that this was going to happen so okay
okay then we on the action listening
minute 69 that's still on going
forever um
minute 59
that's still ongoing
[Music]
jetskis
it says it's completed
jetski i don't know why jet skis are on
there actually
we did this was to review the aspen
strategy
but after the next meeting we should
we should have a lot more to bring back
to them to our committee
in august um
yeah why why is jack's get executed what
was the specific
um action chair from your previous
meeting previous meeting before
one so two meetings ago and it was
part of the call-in as well so you've
actually covered the bit
regarding that and part of the actions
was to set up
the action you know the task to look at
the um the whole s3 strategy yeah
so yeah so that that particular that's
the actual problem
yeah yeah i know you already know you're
moving on now into the
looking at the estuary strategy yeah as
a whole yeah
it could be we'd look at the old
approach to recreation
well all this is going to come into it
anyway you know i mean
it it's not that this is not um
a short a short amount of meetings i'm
sure it's been a decade
a long time to do this this time
anyway meeting 76 cost of zoom we've
that's been completed by sarah yeah
uh i'm gonna take you six
all right you want an email sponsor yeah
yeah that's all fine
by westwood housing that came very
quickly thank you
declarations of interests um
we've got nobody which is new so you all
understand about the declarations of
interest now i'm going to go through a
moment
agent matches brought forth with the
permission of the chair well
what i would like to do is
thank mary for the job that she's done
for us over the years
i mean and she's been fantastic
and what i'm not sure what
we'd all like to do is could we send
a letter to mary from the council from
our committee
um about and haven't given a big thank
you as to what she's done for us over
the years
i mean it must be four or five years but
she's been doing this committee now
okay um next thing i'd like to
welcome steve arden
he's he's new to us but you have
some one or two times before not on this
video
[Music]
yeah all right okay yeah i thought
you've been on that one
i've watched oh you might oh you've
watched
okay anyway nice to have you here
no problem uh also
joe manley um
[Music]
it's been a little bit of a
disagreement this morning about joe but
it's not
supposed to have taken her off this
committee
obviously it's the leader of the council
the statement of this committee because
nasa's chair of ons external
but she was good you did a lot of good
contributions
and i'd like to thank um and
that's about it for me but we will send
this letter to mary
yeah yes sorry
oh yes oh yes i forgot about that
welcome to kirsty a younger
foreign
[Music]
right thank you anyway let's get on now
then right
item seven we've got no part two
item eight
you'll be off for 11 to 45.
hello one
okay so this is the uh council's
performance surpassing the event in
march 21.
um obviously it's been become the year
of kobe pandemic
which had an impact on everything um
obviously
show that i actually think overall
because i've had a really good
performance in a good year
in 2021 then that shows in the qbr
i picked out a few highlights just to
kind of mention this morning
so going to our goals go on is our
economy
um so the customers have helped around
45 million pounds in the actual
government this is four grand to keep
our local economy going
and david's team managed to pay 99
percent because of invoices on time
so it really helps over economy local
businesses
and john the boat center
that's all done and we've had a massive
um
planning area which hasn't happened to
them everywhere else has been in control
we've actually been presently demanding
our planning team
[Music]
there's been a few a few downsides there
to mention one is the
universal trade in the district 130
in the last year so intelligent impact
and pandemic on the local people
um obviously it's getting a good drop in
the level of popularity tax database
because there's less things being built
last year but i think
looking forward that's gonna as more
plans go online
we should catch up on that the future
high street
which isn't successful the good thing
there is looking to get that project
going again
so that could still be a positive
look at our communities um
[Music]
our teams particular chance team worked
with all the local businesses to make
sure the um
other search executives uh rules and
regulations in place to help
everything be incurred and secure um
we did a lot of stuff on the hardship
for other people hatchet payments
we did manage converted property to help
protect the families
the um super extension was extended last
summer to give access to
better access to disabled people to the
flat beach
and there's a lot of council of support
there in financially for the plan art
centre so
cancer is still doing things happening
in the community
in terms of goal three in our
environment
uh last year recycle them was 55.21
which is kind of an increase of just
over one percent which and originally
was really pleased with he wasn't sure
what happened last year
um i think the dollars bottles and
amazon cardboard boxes being delivered
um it's actually really good performance
on the recycling side
we do benchmarking with our kind of sit
for family we've always been like in the
bottom
third and now we're kind of in the top
third this last couple of years it's
been
quite quite a big shift and performance
on that level
um plans have been completing i think
it's been approved now by
members we have the content on
actually increased last year with three
four one two
that's actually yeah absolutely um
i think that's a lot of people kind of
clearing up garages and attics and
shreds
perspective three years ago we used to
do 500 households so
it's still quite it's not quite a good
performance um
just a disaster in terms of goal for
the effective council um obviously
there's a lot of things to keep the
council operating during the pandemic i
think initially
let's keep things going um but we did
that very well
um a lot of homework 156 people working
at home at one point
obviously council meetings went online
so everything i should keep going
tissues kept being made um a vast
range of work coming in across different
services
a new strat plan was completely adopted
and obviously this
is a working party of this um committee
there's actually new performance
reporting
from the next quarter and supposing
there's nothing reduction in stuff
sickness by 40 cent last year
so we actually got a healthier workforce
being covered
a couple of quite willing signs where
the car tax business rate collection
next did fall due to the further 19.
um actually it was so quite high
um what i was expecting i think we still
did quite quite good but obviously
it's quite a lot of money down there um
the
advantage research challenge did
increase as well due to the stamp due to
holiday
and there's just a massive demand on
that team um coming in
there's still the demand now what i've
done the next slide it looks
a bit complicated but it's not quite
explain just trying to explain
the channel shift at the council we've
kind of we've now got data going about
four five six years
of the work coming into different
different channels
so if you look at the blue diamonds
that's actually
the people physically coming to the
reception
so that was kind of falling by about ten
percent a year
and then last year something dropped off
from nineteen thousand nineteen nineteen
hundred so
it just kind of went straight down
because the sector was basically closed
the green boxes that's certain
phone calls being answered by staff you
see that was actually falling
um again about 10 and then it was
leveling off
that's actually gone up um as a
reception close which have obviously
seen more phone calls
so that's actually behind the rise just
this last year
the um purple circles that's actual
website visitors
and that's sure that was kind of that's
our big increase as we're going to ditch
to by default
you see that's rising and rising and
that's going up you know
probably twenty percent a year and i
think this next week's gonna go
significant further as well as we've got
more and more
work online and that becomes a kind of
main way of hitting with the council
red circle there is um telephone calls
being made
which you can see was kind of basically
flat every year
and it did drop off last year but you'll
see from the black circles that that's
the
mobile phone calls being made people
working at home are giving mobiles
so we've been making more phone calls to
customers i think that's because people
have contacted my email
and can have a call back and contact
them check with my telephone
so how can i take phone calls have
actually uh increased
and those are orange circles at the very
top that's our income and email traffic
this is after spam which is actually
emails going through to officers and
counsellors
and certainly
[Music]
[Music]
less reliance on kind of telephones and
come into the office
just to summarize on the next slide to
make it easier to look at i've just
charted the
people coming into the office the blue
ones and uh
the purple thing with actual website
traffic and you just see the actual
difference
there's people falling away coming to
the office it does about 200 a month
you may obviously have to make them up
to
maybe five six thousand it's not going
to go back to what it was
with the website traffic um it's just
gonna get higher and higher so
it's a kind of proper just by default
channel shift at the council
and we can't really see enough in the
figures but any questions
[Music]
any questions
no okay
okay um it's fast to say 2020 21 is
quite a unique
year financially speaking for the
council um
just that you know the report that was
circulated
i had to save draft on it and i'm so
glad i used the word draft
because in the report says the draft
term circus is 964
000. it's actually now 771 000 and
there's a slide in here which will
explain
why that happens so basically
we had covered pressures and lost inc
and there's a chart
there so you've got the biggest thing
was lost council tax and business rate
income
closely followed by our car parking that
particularly was
april may june staff and then to the car
parts for editor
uh we've obviously provided support to
leisure but what we call with related
expenditure like i.t
so we'll take um home working and
ppa and extra cleaning in our homeless
hospitals and our council offices
and then some other bits and pieces such
as the interest receivable everybody
knows the interest rate
in response to the pandemic and that
meant bad income from our
short-term treasury deposits fell off a
cliff essentially
so they're in total the yellow figure
reflects all the pressures that
came about because of colbit on the
council
now fortuitously enough central
government recognises and supported
local authorities
so basically we got grant money so we
got a general code in support granting
four tranches and
to see how government adapted to the
first grant we got 41 000 pounds
and at that point um the council wasn't
looking at a particular healthy position
because we've seen car parking income
going down like two hundred thousand
pounds a month almost and getting 41 000
pounding grant from the government
government recognized that and actually
when the end of the year came we got
just under 1.2 million what they call
general covington programme we also then
got a separate brand for compensation
for lost fees and charges
so victoria district council that was
basically car parking
that's what we've got the money for and
then what we got we got
something called cope with new burdens
that was government recognizing that
we're doing a lot of extra work
in response to the pandemic primarily
the process in a business
program but there's other things that we
did as well
and to be honest the council don't
absorb that work some people officers
did overtime and
some of the business rates went from
part-time to full-time
but we didn't incur a great deal of
additional expenditure it was just taken
off which is another burden the council
officers took on so in total we've got
government grant
that with 1.98 million 1.97 million
apologies
and then there's all the non-covered
related factors
some of these factors may be cold would
relate to our code component to it um
staffing and training we had an
understanding of 600 points certainly
the training
especially 2000 21.
training organizations working with
sending people to university on training
courses
uh just to give context to stacking
under spender about six percent of the
total staff and related budgets
does anybody in this room know that it's
been an unprecedented year in
planning essentially they've basically
doubled what they normally do in a
normal year
so that was a big surplus for the
council various refuge related
a bit more increased recycling means we
get what's called recycling credits from
devon county council which is a reward
for doing more recycling
garden wages and we saved a little bit
on transport maybe that's because of
fuel primarily you'll win
lower than normal so we had about 1.5
million thousand
non-covered variances i would argue that
some of that planning related
matters may have a code component to it
so essentially what that means to come
to the chase and give you the answer
we've been able to put 1.7 million
pounds away into reserves
we're putting 642 000 we made a
contribution to the capital short farm i
think we did that at qbr2
and we've put some other monies into
reserves like backlog maintenance
funding apprentices
and some contribution i think to the
torrington full roof
and here we're in your report he said
we're going to put 964 to the leisure
reserve and seven years they've been
adjusted now because they were drafted
971 thousands to reserve
so we end up the financial year 2020-21
essentially very simplistic central 1.7
billion pounds more than the building
society account when we started the year
just some of the highlights um there's
been an unprecedented amount of cash
that's blowing through the council's
coffers basically because we've been
doing all these business support grants
and obviously being funded by government
at the start of financial year we had
just under 11 million we ended the year
with 17 million pounds in our conference
uh gross spend excluding housing better
than a normal year
24 million um our gross friend is good
housemate this year 66 months
so it's probably the business support
grant and just as a
bit of a pattern back to my team
personally
we normally make about six thousand
payments we've made seventeen thousand
payments this year now
in fairness some of them have been
through a lot of them processed by the
business ratings it's just not the
finance department
itself but i think it would be nice i
personally have very appreciative of
working particularly my team and there's
other teams in the council who have them
well they've risen to the challenge
shall we say
right now this is where i'm going to
lose everybody so apologies in advance
and i'm what i'm trying to do is try to
explain to you why the draft accounts
have moved
we'll just give you some insight into
why that's the case
so we as a billing authority collect
business rates we retain 40 percent of
the business rates 50
business rates going to central
government and 10 percent go to devon
county kevin and the fire
and the rules of the business retention
scheme are that based on
our baseline which is back when the
scheme came into being
fifty percent of any surplus we retain
and if we're not if we're in a business
rate filled 50 surplus goes into
what's called the debt and business
rental which is all the debit
authorities they all throw in their
services 50
of their services if we didn't have a
business rate pill that circles would
just go to 50
i said we'll just go to central
government and we get back
a share with the bill and in the normal
year
we get about 25 percent back of what
we've contributed
to the technical reasons why we don't
get what we put in we don't get back
but it's probably to do with denver
county council being in a deficit
position that's
why that would be however the 2020-21
in response to the pandemic central
government has provided grant income to
partly compensate us for lost business
rate income
so following the writing to that report
that was circulated
in line with deaf and district and
authorities tolerated utilize a company
called lg futures
to revisit our bad debt and appeals
provision
and the result being that both the
provisions have been increased
increasing the deficit on the business
rate income which means we've put
less into the goal however our
government grant income has increased by
145 000 as a result of that
work so we will actually physically get
145 000 pounds more in cash
however the surplus has decreased by 193
to 207 to 771 however
if the provisions are not utilized in
subsequent years
they can be released back into the
driven so essentially what i'm saying is
we've taken a
prudent approach to appeals and bad debt
provision to
maximize one-off central government
grant
that's only available for this year
and there is a possibility that those
provisions may be on the generous side
i'm subsequently released in future
years i
perhaps don't want to say too much more
at this juncture
i'm happy to take any questions anybody
may have at this juncture
[Music]
in that the investments we have looked
at i think we made our first
ethical investment contemporary
investment we actually made our first
one maybe in the first two but i don't
know the top left i know we certainly
made our first spot because i
made sure that peter did it at the
moment we've got more money than we've
ever had
but the rates are one-tenth of what they
were
so going forward the what we'll get
back in temporary investments is be
relevant in in
in reality it's going to be so small so
we have made ethical investments that to
do that but the returns
match the normal uh treasury short-term
depression which is
nothing basically okay
i believe david wants you to make a
recommendation to see in the whole sorry
apologies that's my mistake thank you
john
there is a recommendation in the folks
essentially says i
so the figure of 964 watch changes
i would put a caveat they are
technically still
brought because we haven't got the
videos back from the devon business rate
pool
confirming what we will get out of the
pool and i cannot
i could i can imagine this could be
tomorrow which is after the day we've
got published our draft account so they
are
the 771 is still a draft figure because
i'm dependent
upon figures coming back from colleagues
within the business ripple basically
you can move as fast as the slowest
person can't shoot at him
how can we put a recommendation about it
with that yes sorry simon
um my apologies for being late um
i would move that we recommend
to cnr that the 2021
surplus be set aside to a leisure
reserve
and we omit any figure at this stage
it is the surplus whether it goes up or
down
um i propose that yeah
are you happy with this yes so i might
as well i'll second that
okay although all those in favor
[Music]
we actually going to go through it
the questions have come in which we'll
be looking at
shortly we don't have the opportunity to
raise questions
because it's continually harvesting
continually in red
and what progress is being made to
seek further income every meeting we
have this
material what pages don't be
31.
yeah and what do you want to answer that
question
i mean to be honest i mean we did agree
that we'd ask questions on the qbr
in advance to meet so officers should be
available to um
respond now sean is on annual lead this
week he'd be the best person
there is a harvard question within the q
a anyway
there's a lot in the qpr report we're
asking questions at the meetings and
obviously officers didn't know the
answer to
every last bit of detail so the approach
we adopted was to ask questions in
advance
give officers time to pull
answers together which is why we've done
this
yeah well i may be but i thought of
previous meetings we've had written
questions and answers but also the
opportunity to raise questions
i don't think so i don't think we've
raised any questions at
the meeting when we've had copies of
this i mean
this is this is quite short to what we
normally
normal questions and that's what we
normally get but
yeah in future we have to seek
information like
submitting written info well the idea
was that because
because we used to ask questions before
and officer that did then go away and
then
supply us with an answer so we we
produce these
questions prior to a reasonable time for
our prior to our meeting
so that people then could they can get
the answer for us and
we we have it written and we so we've
got it
yeah have you not seen the
questions and answers yeah
[Music]
so just think about it before then peter
that you
get your questions in early
okay
john sorry yeah just to say that some of
the questions that was just raised will
be covered with the estuary and task and
finish grouping yes
we've circulated
so they will be sending information back
into their working group
and ultimately the committee working
groups in
two weeks and yeah yeah yeah second
second meeting that will be
okay right
in that recommendation that we've just
done then uh we
receive a note the qbr do we is
everybody in agreement with that
no problem okay so that includes the
written questions
we have questions
you've all got a copy of the questions
and answers
okay i'll go through more on page two
um if you'd be awful matt okay you're
happy with that anyway simon
[Music]
we're quite happy with that
maintenance backlog gender page 11
leisure maintenance backlog question for
me and offer
everybody ready everybody happy with the
answer
especially yeah everybody other than
that yeah
okay page three
leisure reserve recommendation which is
on
agenda page 12.
this was sent in by steve steve denke
everybody understand the the question
and everybody happy with the answer
just i mean i guess in the view of the
fact that
the surface will change it's just a
question where that knocks on
into cash flow and revenue
in later years but i appreciate it still
too early class
but it would be good to know when it's
not too early to ask
well they won the audience conclusive
i'll ask them
okay uh
and reporting agenda page 14.
um yeah
we've all read that income monitoring
agenda page 16. mr harper
it was about the album
just wondering why it continues to be
and it was a matter that was um brought
up in the last
cardboard last week and one of the
questions that frequently comes in
is can the car parking income be used to
um
assist the harbor but but the age old
person
i'm sure our finance manager will will
confirm it's one bank account
that they're effectively budget lines so
it it makes
no difference in intelligence terms um
but what i can say is that richard haste
is currently conducting a review of the
harbour
and trying to increase um harbor income
but it
it is notoriously difficult um bearing
in mind that the tides and
and the type of apartment that we have
but um
if you're interested it may be a good
idea to sit on hoverboard and then
hoverboard subsequently
feeds into cnr so i sent a report
recommendation yeah absolutely if
there's a new recommendation
to to make other than that richard
reports in the operational matters to
harvard board and
it's discussed there but i mean it is an
age-old question
it comes up frequently the harbor
has always been a loss loss-making
entity
but it's not all about making money it's
about
the good of the community people like
the harbor the historic so
there's lots of other factors to take
into account um
and obviously we could only have a
certain amount of ships in at a certain
time because we are
very tidal so it does get discussed
quite quite frequently
but i i know at the moment richard and
his team
are currently reviewing uh with a view
to maximizing income as much as possible
but whether it will ever be a profit
making
um you know it remains to be seen
effectively but
but in the car parking you come into
harbor isn't
[Music]
yeah i mean this is a question that's
come up several times since i've been a
counselor
you know the harbor does struggle a lot
but of course
what we've got to um bear in mind of
course is the back office
on costs and to the hard work and
all our services that's true they all
cost the same so
if the harbour board is making
it is good you know it's not making a
profit sometimes you're going to look at
and i think the slim what you should do
is look at back office
on cost to overall services um
you know we've got the the legal side
the
the i.t side and all these other things
that
are put onto our services
whether or not they're they're making a
lot of money or not
so the own costs are the same yeah
yeah but the the harvest looked at is a
cost center which is
which is different from from europe or
others which is support services across
the
so i don't think that's a fair analogy
change actually that
doesn't it doesn't really make sense
yeah the harvard doesn't make a
a positive cash contribution before the
on costs
so the only cost to be honest the on
costs that are put on
are really the statutory government
returns into being perfectly honest
we don't use them internally the um what
we call internal recharges we're obliged
to do them
the statutory government returns because
the government wants all councils to
report its expenditure in a certain way
and so it's used by central government
it's not used internally within the
council
and that's it the simple truth is that
the
other and partnership income that comes
in doesn't mean the expenditure that
directly goes out that's directly
related to the harder part of concerns
because we've said before
that the um
hard to say but but perhaps you know
if we can stop looking through race
tinted glasses and and
actually look at repurposing the harbor
for something that is actually fit for
the modern market
uh as a really good quality tourist
attraction or whatever
uh and ditch that they'd be
hanging on to a historic
harbour background which costs money and
is no longer
it's no longer viable we know that in
this modern day and age
and um how long do we go on
actually using taxpayer
uh money on a what is really a historic
maintaining a historic reputation uh
which i don't think
does anything to draw actual uh tourism
or other income into the town either
um but um we have we've been here many
times and um
until the the burgers of biddeford um
roll over and accept that actually they
need to look forward rather than back
um we're always going to be stuck with
this this ongoing loss
well said frankly it's quite it's
getting rather tiresome as well but
i've only been asked to yet
well we are actually they are before
well they are but we're going to we'll
come into the estuary strategy which
we're trying to do at the moment so
yeah i mean i do agree with simon
but okay we'll move on
all right chair
yes sorry mr fischoed
[Music]
[Music]
do you want me to explain a little bit
further could you
could you yeah i noticed what you said
was a response that is incorporating a
general industrial
um units
surely if we're actually charging people
rental
um we've got tenants we ought to have
all the costs there
and be able to identify the the
fish stock particularly as a concept
exactly the same as cadstown which has
down blue
yeah i'm not saying it was impossible i
was just saying it was uh
been in that so just to explain
[Music]
non-visual things okay so the cost of
some industrial units and the fish stock
all go under one accounting customs
we have um something called a job code
which that'll identify fist off from the
rest of the spend
in the industrial unit so we do identify
the spend
identifier the income
is in the it goes on a job code which is
the name of the business
that's renting the premises so in order
to get um
the issue i'd have to get a colleague to
get their track the fish stock
expenditure
and then go through a list of all the
income codes
and separate them between fish stock and
non-fish stock customers
to arrive at where the fish stock is i'm
not saying it's not something i can't
do but it's not something i can pull off
a report and do i have to
you'd have to involve manual
intervention from an officer
to do that and um if this committee
wishes that to be done then
obviously we can go and deal with
understanding i cannot
press the button and tell you in that
position of the fish stop without
actually doing
a little bit of work that would probably
take an officer an hour or so
look at the beginning of the day yeah
when we set the rents for our attempts
yeah all the all the various costs are
actually taken into account
that's really what my questions are yeah
as well so
the cost will be in terms of the gas and
the utility costs etc
how do they incorporate when we need we
know we need some capital investment in
there and we incorporate that that's
another matter
in terms of purchasing equipment that
needs to be refreshed that's in our
capital programme
that's capitals yeah but with the
revenue as well so
you're saying the fact is that we
actually allow the tenants the
use of power and light and heating but
they're charged they're charged
yes yes they are yeah there's some
enforcement of some
shared area costs and then there's
separate meters and that's part of it
it was quite an undertaking from aidan
redwood in the team when they took over
the first stop because
it had to do that sort of separate
building that wasn't necessarily
available at the time
thank you very much do you like any
better
you're right after that well i propose
that we do
said i cannot press the phone and say
here's the expenditure
stuff i can do i probably can do the
expenditure of money i can't press the
button because that's the
income stock i'd have to print off all
the income
in the industrial units that this stock
is included and then someone would have
to go through and say oh that's a fish
stock customer that's the fish stock
customer
that's a pissed off customer and right
i'm saying it would involve an officer
potentially an hour of an officer's time
to do that right okay
so we happy with that yeah we need to
know
you know as a as a committee what what
contribution
is making really if we're going to
assess it it is a as a one-off
one-off exercise with it yeah not as a
regular no
no no one it's a one-off exercise yeah
time well it makes a lot funny
you know the answer is
why are you asking the question more
okay we can ask david to do that
yeah okay if you would like me to bring
it will it
be our next meeting in august i think
it's probably
circulated okay that's fine okay
yeah it's quite happy all right
move on
my phone try to skip the picture
agent uh budget monitoring at gender
phase 17
we've got that question from steve
um everyone happy with sarah's
answer yeah very good
okay uh
go warm prosperous and sustainable
economy agenda page 19-21
mr harper
question everybody answer
everybody happy
hey that means you as well ian happy
the only comment i'd make is that we had
a
draft strategy already in cube and
qbr one how long does it take such a
long time to uh
come through and say i do appreciate the
fact that we've had code
and things have actually taken over but
yes i
i'm happy with the response okay
page 19 tvc hospitality
question answered happy with the answer
yeah you have to answer the question
[Music]
next question is about airband i can't
complain about it but
i think it's great for me i think it's
awful
absolutely awful okay
right um you're very lucky that chair
yeah yeah well yeah i understand about
your
what what's the problem with your
broadband anyway don't um
anyway you've got the answer to that ian
there happy
yeah yeah 35 then
go to agenda page 22 to 25
affordable housing um question from
yeah happy with the with the answer
everybody read the answer
probably only half quite frankly is
every year
the target for affordable housing is
171.
every year we fall short so therefore by
that we're not just
short by 12 to 171 this year
we're continuously sure we're sure now
we've been
probably not into the hundreds of
thousands yeah
and i think that's an issue and i do
appreciate it's a difficult issue it's
an issue that uh other councils and
other people have but it's an issue that
i've noticed in cornwall particularly
that's one of the questions i raised in
hospitality that people can't
get the jobs but can't actually live
there and i'm sure that we're coming
toward towards that way slowly but
yeah i think you're right
so everybody happy about that answer
yeah okay
questions and answers
i'm truly blessed um
myself mr harper and steve hurst met to
discuss them the capital case
uh how we may change the evaluation of
the capital piece and the ranking of the
capitol pits
we agreed that probably was best for
taking florida through a task and
finished with just to update in the
background my colleague peter hudson is
the capital accountant
the council has actually formulated um
a way we may go forward in terms of
scoring this
and making decisions about whether they
go forward or not
i think probably the best thing would
actually
do actually set up the task and finish
group um
you know a few councils maybe myself and
peter and we go through his
as a starting point what he's um pulled
together
and then and then we'll probably maybe
use um
he's a colleague of mine joe wells from
the house of benefits she's gonna have a
suggestion
um a capital investment we may maybe as
an exercise actually go through that and
see how that scores
and what happened do we think it's fit
for purpose and maybe that might be the
approach going forward
we would need to move relatively quickly
because
really by the end of september that's
when we really need to start thinking
budget's going forward and capital bids
going forward so
i think it should be fairly truncated
with the tasks and finished with it
shouldn't go on too long
there could be one or two meetings and
any suggestions that the members of that
task can finish
if you know peter would turn that round
very quickly and we'd have hopefully
have something in place by
we'd probably have to have this for
three by four councils the approach that
we take
so i've just um voice over future to
solicit membership of a task and finish
group and then we
get these dates in the diaries and try
to move forward with this process
okay so we want to set up a task and
finish group
and i would suggest to start with mr
harper is on it
um who else would like to be on it
obviously i'll be on it because
come on simon simon you want to be on it
okay
anybody else that's only three of us
anybody steve i can be on it
help okay
that's enough for thing
okay okay
you'll set that up yeah okay no problem
uh
and you've got first data
times really yeah yeah
no problem yeah
what you're looking at we need to do it
pretty quick well i'm just saying that
we're now just coming to july i ideally
need to be certainly if we can't be
letting this run beyond the end of
september
right okay so we've got basically three
months
to the end of september okay all right
we'll sort of down
like that pretty quick okay
all right move on five to the ten
well you know i think i told you
we've started the estuary strategy we we
had our first meeting
um we have got one or two things out now
that
um officers are looking at
for when we have our next meeting in two
weeks so
yeah um we tried to have our meeting
very
very close together like we did with the
with the qbr so we've got momentum
but yeah nothing really to to report it
yet but
we should have more much more to report
in august
okay
all right we'll come on to the annual
report
you've all seen the annual all seen the
annual report
and to be quite honest this is the first
time i've ever seen one because
for 10 years i've been on this committee
and i have never seen internal do an
annual report
as john was a bit shocked as well
but but yeah um we you will
have you all read the annual report yeah
[Music]
actually i'll be honest
what happened was mary set something out
just to do a report
then i got notified that about us having
a report
well she'd already put things together
and
and as i say i have never known
that internal do an annual report
not well i've been on internal and
so i was a bit shocked to be quiet and i
think john
john walter was as well because he
didn't realize either
but yeah the credit the credit goes to
mary
basically mary's valedictory yes
i mean she she did it and
within a couple of days did we quite
honest what did johnny it was
it's just very quick and then we looked
at it
et cetera et cetera and we put it down
yes shirley i know about the the
strategy
yeah so i mean i was wrecking my brains
it may
make me look very stupid but i couldn't
remember if the play strategy was
discussed at
length not not the not the um question
that came back about it but whether it
was discussed at length
internal or external was it this
committee no
it was like in which case it shouldn't
be enough but they
i mean i extern will do one
we'll see how it goes nation
constitution
constitution
thank you very to vary into much
oh yeah yeah it's just under the qbr
review i just wonder if it's worth
noting that we
were putting in a new section about
carbon
reporting in the kingdom
[Music]
well we know that he's going to go in
uh but to be quite honest
um i don't feel that we should
leave this any longer and then take it
back out and redo it
but
um
simon tony
second yeah all those in favor
yeah okay you know steve
aren't you oh sorry i put my hand up
yeah all right
okay
right item 12 consideration of the
forward plan
but anybody put anything into
the ksp to save it we've got things to
move forward
and he's going to write a few things
down what all of you are going to say
you would like to go on to the forward
plan
yeah yeah you've done that have you i
have one
yeah okay well that can go down firstly
which is i think we've got to do it this
way because
we do keep trying to get things on the
front and
which we don't we have got a reasonable
amount of stuff on the forward plan
anyway um but yeah it would be nice if
we could just
you know if there's anything that we've
missed
and it was making sure that it's kind of
a link to our strategic priorities chair
wasn't it yeah exactly
right do you want to put mr harper's one
on there first
my favorite peer review
what happened i should have said that
right okay
the last one was in 2017 just four years
old now
yeah um i thought we did very volumes
yeah i don't know what's happened since
the the kind of the covey pandemic it is
a
dinner could we could we check up on
that john
if we are due for a peer review spaces
have been
you know it's been discussed at
management sessions
don't you have discussions
could you could would you like that next
time
thank you if we are due for a period
2017. yeah
[Music]
should be reviewed every year just to
see where you're going what's what needs
to be done wrong yeah
you know it's it's someone's giving you
some information
then you ought to be taking that up and
just moving it forward
it's not about hitting people or
anything else it's about looking at the
thing and saying okay
have we achieved that five do we what
else do we need to do as well
i believe the committee did look at it a
few years ago and it was kind of
agreed that it kind of it was kind of it
moved on with the
improvement plan and everything else so
it was kind of
out of date i don't think we really
looked at it
i thought that she had a paid service at
the time
brought it to the meeting and it was
discussed
couple of years ago i'm sure yes
yeah yeah if you would yeah i can't
remember it was having a
good conversation about it yeah
strategy that if we'd actually looked at
yesterday's strategy
way back we've actually identified the
fact that
it wasn't actually being enacted upon um
in other words one of the things that
one of the key
issues on it was that it should the um
the aims should actually be identified
and none of this
actually happened i mean you're spending
38 000 pounds on
on a piece of work and doing nothing
with it right all right no
you aren't yeah but you're picking bits
out of it you're not actually doing it
properly
and i look at things like the uh the
economy and perhaps those sorts of
things ought to just review it every so
often
because it's like everything else i've
always been told that
if you have a business plan right in the
back packet
review it regularly make sure it's an
active and working document
i have a feeling sometimes that some of
the documents we have
are just it's a means to an end it's
what we're supposed to do by government
someone else we've got that there and
we're not actually doing anything with
it
can we check with stacey
which is gonna your what is it called
the super management meeting yeah
senior management oh see problems with
you
so could you could you bring that up
there for us and to ask
if we are due for a review
uh because if we do for a peer review
there's not really much
point in going look looking through this
old one is that
if we're in for a new one
no i i'd still say at the end of the day
you should review things
okay thanks okay right regardless okay
that's fine but we'll check we'll check
with senior management
first you like the previous chat uh uh
peer review to put on the
um agenda for the next meeting so that
members can consider it and then at the
same time
monday i will raise whether it's prudent
to have a further
peer review or if we do for one
basically
i i thought it was supposed to be every
four years
i think it's more voluntary check yes
yeah that's not right
okay i think we were one of the a few
that actually
did two what in within two or three
years
so we were one of the top 20 or
something you
who did a regular regular one so okay
mate
that's fine right we'll move on hey uh
it's steve first yeah i was just
wondering what is a peer review because
yeah yeah like i i mean from mr dude it
sounds like it's a
performance update whether you've you
know how things are working and whether
you're getting on with it do you want me
to yeah you answered john yeah it's a
very good question i'm sorry we didn't
explain it
it's conducted by external uh people
um from other councils and from the lga
so they bring in a little team of um
individuals with different skills
um some counsellors some senior officers
and they come in and they look at
various aspects of of the performance
and the culture and everything of the
authority
um and then they they provide a a report
to
you know kind of recommendations of how
they think you could improve
it's pretty cool elsewhere
all right nicely thank you
okay sarah i have okay suggestion i
don't know how you're dealing with you
are we taking anybody
so john are you taking anything yeah
yeah
yeah
i'm just i'm just reminding myself of
what it
is we do and i'm just reading um here
on our terms of reference because
actually that's normally quite a good
way of focusing back onto
what we should be and just looking at
the first one which was that we are to
scrutinize decisions
made or actions taken in connection
with the discharge of any of the
council's functions
including decisions taken by cnr
or by an officer i think given
the unusual year plus that we've had
um not that i'm necessarily
thinking that it's it it's been
done wrongly but i think from a
security uh from a scrutiny point of
view
we should satisfy ourselves that the
emergency procedures
process has been properly and correctly
used
uh it's been used quite extensively
during a pandemic
understandably notice it's still going
on there were two in cnr yesterday
um and i would suggest that we should
satisfy ourselves
that it is properly being used
and not been abused to short-circuit
things
on onto the the agenda
and if necessary we invite the leader
and the chief executive to come
and actually justify their
frequent signing up to emergency
procedures
actions okay fine
sorry that's a bit slightly out of the
box but i got
i've been finished now it was actually
steve dungate
should have been before you oh sorry
steven but we'll finish that
yeah yeah yeah okay
right next step so i think i've
raised it in an email but it may be that
it will be something that we'll look at
on the pid review but it's something we
discussed as one of the tasks and
finished groups on qpr
and that is whether we are looking at
trying to determine a social value
measurement
um as a council and how we build that
end
so the comment was made about how the
harbour brings in
value how people like it that's the sort
of thing
there's other areas that look at social
value and giving indication
i'm not sure we have as a council
a current should we put it that way um
social value indicating it could
be a good point to review i think if
we're looking
yeah yeah and then another one would be
we
we have in the past looked at housing
the housing and empty properties a lot
but i just wanted a house in general a
scenario that we
will need to consider at some point
because of what comments were about
social housing not being i know it's a
big issue and i know it's it's affecting
other
countries as well but it would be good
to have a clear understanding of what
the
district needs are measured against what
we actually provide
okay fine yeah
we'd be doing that at the moment after
we've got a working partner looking at
it
so i mean surely we're doing a bit of
duplication surely we should allow the
working party
to to conclude and counsel it
necessarily to
to conclude its views on it then if
necessary we then bore into
the just the the views and decisions
that have been taken but
if we start looking at it now well we've
already
there's specifically a task that's been
handed out
on this very subject elsewhere within
the council at the moment
that's right john yeah we've got a we've
got a meeting with the um
company that helping us with it in two
weeks time yeah
yeah yeah um so that's feeding into the
strategic plan action of about
provide you know becoming a provider
housing provider or other options so
it would probably make sense to let that
do its path and
have a recommendation of full council
first and yeah and see what comes out of
that
yeah it's up to you yeah i think i think
that's the better i do
at the moment do you want to say
something
yeah um so that piece of work is already
underway okay um
yeah on the social value that's quite
useful in terms of looking at council
procurement policy which
we're hoping to do um on another matter
am i mistaken that we normally have a
list of sort of queueing list
of other items to consider
that was an old very old list that's why
we're doing this
is to try to start building a new list
for that
okay
anybody else
you will start looking at how we can put
that onto your agenda
yeah when your next meeting is quite
full anyway isn't it but
yeah yeah well yeah i mean they always
need to
give your one which we will i think
we'll have a good look at
because it's coming in the new format
yeah
trans maintenance contract update let's
see
where we're going there extra strategy
update and testing finish
from the test and finish group but we
should we could have quite
a reasonable amount of stuff to come
back from the asterisk actually this
time
yeah so we'll have a look to see what's
going on yeah do you want to
add these to any of your future meetings
or do you want to do that after
we'll do it after john we've got we've
got the list that we've
yeah we're looking for sorry pop in one
extra thing
perhaps on cycle 4 in september
yeah did we put qbr format review in
that
in that we will have we will have gone
for the new format
on qbl one all right which will have
then gone out
yeah we then ought to i mean we're all
sold on it and we're
preaching to converted here but we
actually ought to go out to perhaps
other people who could or
should be reading or taking an interest
in the qbr
and actually try to get a bit of
feedback to find out we could put that
out to all counselors
well indeed say that and before
at cycle four we're giving ourselves a
prompt
to say let's just review
what it is we've done and see whether
it's actually ticking the box or not
yeah um yeah because uh we should never
be frightened of tweaking it if it's not
right
that's fine something it's just a little
bit earlier than what i thought we'd do
it but
that's
coming back to the housing one um is it
worth just putting it on there
sort of late on in the cycle but just as
um
i know we're going to be looking at it
and we've got these workshops and
everything but is it worth just putting
it on there just so that we check on the
progress
of that and the other thing is i mean
you may say to me this
this is external not but i i would
definitely
want to see the progress of the play
strategy as well should that be external
rather than internal
that's that's that's that'll be external
okay
that external have been looking at the
play strategy yeah
well for months now aren't you simon
you're on to external aren't you well
it's i am too yeah but i mean
okay you can go on that one there
there's a project the progress
okay thank you i know it exists but that
happened it comes to a different [ __ ]
if they've done something wrong
that's true
right so we've got them things down
there yeah we'll go through
i mean yeah the other thing we've got on
later on
yeah happy with that everybody happy
with that yeah
okay
thank you all for coming have a nice